good afternoon members uh
officers and members of the public who
may be watching
um the planning committee on the um
authority's youtube youtube channel
uh the planning committee of the 15th of
july
um as usual i think we're getting used
to this now
um i will go through a list uh it's not
in alphabetical order i've had this from
when we first started this i do know
there are some apologies
um which will come to when on the agenda
item but if i call your name out
um please say yay if i don't hear
anything i know
obviously someone's not here so
counselor organ
here come to the duckworth
here thank you councillor zeki
yeah councillor dennis
councillor bayford here chair
councillor coleman cook here chair
councillor hart here jeff councillor
right
here chair councillor ghana
i'm here yeah thank you councillor scott
here chair and i got your message
counselor thank you
uh councillor moore i know um
myself obviously um
i will come to any other any people
other people because i know we have
some substitutes today in a moment
officers
estelle our legal officer
i believe she has joined us yes hello
chair sorry
i was like thank you estelle emily uh
committee clark hi i'm present
ian livingston planning applications
manager
hello chair president of you and i
believe it's
emma today um presenting or is it
yourself ian
yes i'm present right thank you emma
right as as always uh just a few
housekeeping notes
you don't have to wear any masks while
we're on um here just to let you know
uh if you have any technical
difficulties during this meeting please
contact
democratic services officer on call
who will attempt to assist you today's
officer
is charlotte and her number is 507
one nine her number will be included in
the top of the chat
stream box for your convenience
i've been asked all participants when
you are not speaking please
mute your microphone this minimizes
background noise
and will help everyone in who's listened
to the proceedings
microphones must be only used
when the participant has been granted
permission to speak
to gain permission to speak please very
briefly indicate on the chat box
on the side right hand side of your
screen
and i will then make a note that you
wish to speak
with everybody uh president please
ensure that the mobile phones are turned
to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive
phone calls whilst the meeting is in
progress
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting any other business and
ensure that you are in a quiet room
through from
any distractions that for the duration
of this meeting
would you please note that the meeting
is being streamed live
to members of the public and following
the meeting
the recording will be available on the
council's youtube
channel members requesting to speak
under council procedure 21
20.1 i believe there
might be if i'm wrong i apologize to you
are there any other members
okay uh public speaking
the following patients have been
reserved for public speaking
with members please note that the forum
item
on the agenda which is 4b
r02 that's public speaking
agenda item 1 apologies for absence
i have received apologies from
councillor auburn but that's not correct
uh councillor keen councillor curry
uh to whom councillor harry scoby
is present and from councillor taylor
for whom councillor roses is present
now i believe we have some substitutes
i've seen come up on my screen
can anybody we do have um additional
apologies
um counselor dennis has um since given
his apologies as well
right i i'm not aware of
anybody else um here as a
substitute me and slur scoby and
thank you emily for that it's purely
we've been having a chat before the
meeting
went live thank you agenda item 2
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest
no minutes of the planning committee
held on the 17th
june the members agree that the minutes
of the planning committee
held on the 17th of june 2020 be
approved
and signed by myself uh could i have a
proposal please
propose a name
please for proposing yeah councillor
chesky
thank you councillor zesky uh second
please
thank you uh do you all agree
i agree yeah great thank you that
agenda item for scheduled or planned
applications and public speaking
uh once again regarding site visits
they will only take place when it is
safe to do so
and listening to the news as i think we
do here i'm
not sure when that will be um so a
gender item 4b which is a planning
application
for refusal at 91 botany road
broadcast i would ask estelle
to read out a statement from
mr eldridge thank you
thank you chair we know that personal
circumstances are not generally taken
into account
when planning applications are
considered but we have written to the
planning committee
to explain the reasons why this is a
retrospective application
and it is through no fault of our own
that we ended up with a dormer larger
than previously approved
and additions finished in a material
different to the main roof
especially when the work was overseen by
one of the council's building inspectors
we have also previously circulated to
members details of other dormer
extensions in botany road
which we feel are not so different to
ours with cladding having been approved
elsewhere
and which we feel sets a clear precedent
for the use of cladding in our case
we are extremely concerned that the
stated ground for refusal
says that there is an issue with the two
dormers on the left side of the bungalow
but the enforcement notice did not
require their removal
and we feel that this is inconsistent
and unreasonable
with the possibility that if the
application is refused
we could be served with another notice
demanding their demolition
as far as the approved cladding used on
the dormer up the road at number 51
although it might tie in with the colour
scheme on the ground floor
this could change as a result of
redecoration going completely against
the council's thinking
in exactly the same way we could paint
our ground floor in a colour that
matches the cladding on the dormers
similarly we could paint our dormers in
a colour which more close
closely matches the tone of the roof
tiles and is something we are more than
prepared to do
should counsellors feel that the present
color of the cladding is unacceptable
in fact when the matter was first raised
and things were better financially
we did offer to replace the cladding
with tile hanging that this was declined
and we are not now in a position to
afford to make the same offer
but we could repaint the dormers in a
different color which could be made the
subject of a condition
whereby we could then agree with
officers a preferred choice of color
we clearly hope that the committee agree
with us
that the dormers are not so harmful to
the area
and approve their retention but we also
hope that the offer to repaint
helps to reassure members that we are
more than prepared to work with officers
to find a mutually acceptable resolution
thank you thank you estelle
speaking on behalf of mr john elvidge
would ask the planning officer to give
an outline of the report
emma please
i'm just um sharing the presentation
with you now so
um this is the application site outlined
in red
and so it's halfway down uh botany road
the um this shows the aerial view of
the site so the application site is in
the center of the screen here
so there's a retrospective application
so these photos that you're now going to
see are showing the
proposal um it's for roof alterations
which include
three door windows um the central one
you can see to the front of the site
here
and two side normal windows along with
an extension of the roof to the rear so
this is standing to the front of the
property
looking looking at the uh the proposal
this is then taken from the right hand
side of the property so you can see
um the dormer on the right hand side
and the design and the materials that
have been used on this
and then this is showing it further away
so you can now start to see the
neighboring properties that it's a in a
road full of modest sized bungalows
although a number of properties in the
road have have had alterations at roof
level
so again you can see the uh dormer
windows
in the in the distance here and you can
see on the right there are some
other properties that have been extended
so then this is
from the left hand side looking towards
the property again you can see the front
door
and the projection on the right hand
side and now you can see the left hand
side as well which consists of
two separate dormers flat roof and again
with the uh blue gray cladding
and then this is looking towards the
application site in the distance here so
you can see the property
in the distance so you can see it's
quite a prominent property within the
street that does have long views of
of the development and and then this is
just showing examples of other
properties in the street so this is
standing outside the application site
looking um
opposite on the other side of the road
at um existing properties
and then this is just looking again from
outside the application
site to the south away from
the beach area and again showing um the
properties in the street so again you
can see some other examples of roof
extensions
but in the majority of cases that you
can see and toll hanging has been used
for the dorm windows
so this was the existing um front
elevation
and then this is what has previously
been approved so there's been
two previous applications one has been
approved and one has been refused
so there's an initial application for
smaller dormer windows which has been
approved and the normal windows also
approved with toll hanging
so this was what was expected to have
been constructed on site
the um an application then came in
following this for the larger
development which you
you saw in the photos and we have
previously refused this development
so this application is a resubmission of
that same proposal
with very very minor amendments so this
is then
the the previously proved one uh we have
no
concerns with the size of the front
dormer or with the size of the dormers
on the left-hand side
so the biggest impact is your as you'll
see through the plans is the right-hand
side dormer which has
um as enlarged in size so this is the
approval and then this is now what's
been built so again you can see the
front door remains the same the left
hand side dorman remains the same but
the right hand side dormer
has significantly increased in both
depth and width
and then this is now looking on the
left-hand side of
the um building as existing
then this is what has been approved with
the reduced
um the size of the dormers
and this is what's been
built so the distance to eve's level and
the distance the ridge level from both
dormers
remains the same as previously approved
so that the dormers are not
significantly different
to that previously considered to be
acceptable um
again the the main difference though is
the use of materials so previously
these were both tile hung and as you can
see from the photos
um blue grey um timber cladding has now
been used on
these dormers and then this is to the
other side
um as existing this is the size of the
dormer
that was approved so again you can see
the distance from the bottom of the door
mark to the eaves level
and again the distance from the height
of the dormer to the bridge level
and you can also see the the width of
the dormer
and then this is now the proposed or the
as built
dormer so this dormer is 1.4 meters
deeper than the the previous approval so
that's taking it down to almost the age
level of the property
and it's all also 1.7 meters wider than
the previous approval so
it's now a total of 7.5 metres wide and
a total of 3.7 meters deep
and again you can see um that the
cladding has been used rather than the
tile hanging
and so the extension that comes out
above the single story level
at the rear this roof extension here
again this is previously part of the
previous approval and only very minor
changes in terms of the
size of the v-luxes is proposed within
this area so we don't have any
real concerns with that and then this is
the
was the existing rear elevation before
the alterations and this is now
what's happened so it's now became again
become a gay blend at the rear
and because of the the roof extension
that's occurred and again you can see
this the size of the dormer
on the left hand side there and then
this is just showing the existing
floor plan of the property and then as
built floor plans showing the extension
out to the rear this was the roof
planned previously as existing
and this is now as built so um
so what's been um what was stated within
the
statement that's been submitted by the
applicant with regarding the staircase
area so you can see that area to the
center of the site here
so it would appear that in during
construction
um in order to achieve this staircase
within within the roof conversion
it's resulted in the the dormer
increasing in depth
um in terms of impact on neighbours
there was previously not considered to
be any impact on neighbours as all of
these windows that you can see
in both sides of the dormers are either
secondary windows
or the non-habitable room windows and
therefore it was pretty agreed that all
of these windows would be obscure gray
so there's not considered to be
any overlooking to neighbors from from
this first floor accommodation
so if i just flick back through um
to the photos
so the the biggest issue is to do the
the dominant size of this
dormer on the right-hand side and also
the use of materials
um it's considered that it unbalances
the property and given the
the size of this dormer it appears um
dominant with it within the roof gate of
this this modest building
and given the fact it's quite prominent
you can see it along long views along
boston road
um it's considered to be out of keeping
with um
the proportions of the existing building
architecturally unrelated to the
existing building
in terms of materials it's not
considered to appear um
well related to the the materials that
have been used on the existing building
you can see there's
brick and painted render at ground floor
level and then
red round tiles at um roof level
so the use of this blue grey cladding is
considered to be completely out of
keeping
with the appearance of this building so
it's
it's therefore recommended for refusal
on the grounds of the size of the
doormat and the user materials thank you
chairman
thank you emma i move the officer's
recommendation is adopted could i have a
second
please
could i have a second please thank you
dude
secretary thank you very much uh
councillor zesky
um members you wish to debate yes uh
cancer album
yeah thank you chair question please for
officer um
uh emma the letter that was read out on
behalf of the
applicants uh made reference to
uh officers refusing it uh
the the dormer to be tall hung i mean is
that
it's total opposite to what you just
said so can you just confirm
for us please um yes that's fine um
so in order to try and rectify the
situation um with the fact that
permission had not been given
for a dormer of this size and obviously
the materials have been used
and from what i understand the applicant
has had put forward
a proposal to toll hang the dormers but
it was considered by officers that
on its own that was not enough because
it was the size of the doormat as well
as the top as well as the use of
materials it was a problem so
we have no concerns at all with the use
of tile hanging and obviously would
support that that's what we previously
have
approved um but it was in addition we
would have required the
the dormer to be reduced in size so it's
a
i mean tile hanging it would obviously
reduce some impact but it's the
cumulative impact of the materials and
the size of the dormer that we have
concerns with
thank you very much did you wish to come
back council robin no
thank you chair uh councillor joe
bayford
thank you chair uh this application has
given me
um some some grief uh
i'm on the face of it guidance has been
given and not adhere to that can't be
denied
but i do feel that the applicants have
had misleading information as well
um i've walked up and down the road
and i have to say i don't think it looks
out of place
there are so many different uh versions
of this
up and down the road um it is big it
can't be denied but i don't think it
stands out
i think the coloring looks okay but i
also understand that um
when a refusal is made the applicant
should adhere to that
and i wouldn't want to set a precedent
for
for sort of breaking the the rules that
have been set
um but i have to say i i do think
that it looks okay thank you chad
thank you councilman ford uh councillor
linda wright
thank you chairman um i i get what jill
is saying but
um i do feel that um
the red people people know the rules
about retrospective
developments and i do think people do
i'm not saying this applicant has done
it but i think we have to
we have to we have to honor the the
views of the
officer because people do use the
retrospective
ro to force through an application that
they know
that nobody's going to going to do
anything about and so therefore set a
president
i actually do think it's hideous if if
if i can be blunt um and i will be
supporting the officers officer's
recommendation thank you thank you
councillor wright uh
councillor common cook
thank you chair the the letter that
um estelle read out
said that the um building
inspector gave advice
to them that was deemed to be wrong
is that correct am i correct in saying
that because it just seems to me
i've got to say i agree with uh
councillor
bayford uh councillor wright
i disagree totally with you because of
if they received from the
building inspector uh advice
and it was wrong then that's not their
fault
so thank you chair
uh do you wish to come back on that emma
at all um yes if that's okay
um i think i think the issue is
obviously there's the two processes
there's planning permission and
there's um building regulations now from
a builder control perspective point of
view they would have
gone out to inspect it during
construction and to check that
um that they were constructing it
properly and
i think from what i understand the
staircases caused the issue
and perhaps the drawings that maybe were
originally drawn weren't
um large enough to achieve the size of
staircase that was needed
and so they would have been given advice
by the building control inspector
on the construction side of things now
obviously what would then need to have
occurred is for them to come
back to planning to for them to have
had an amendment agreed um to that
proposal because they obviously had to
build in accordance with the approved
plans
so um i believe that's what's happened
so i don't it's not an error that's
occurred in terms of advice that's been
given
um it would be that the building control
inspector would have given advice under
their legislation but that differs to
planning legislation
uh thank you for that emma um councillor
alban wish to come back
yes thank you chair uh just just on that
point uh
that councilor carmel cook raised um
you know that's a bit of a red herring
really um they've
chucked that in there uh it's got
nothing to do with the planning process
um however the question the question
that i have here is that
um now understand the enforcement notice
that's been served
on the property can the um officer
please clarify
exactly what the enforcement notice is
for uh
what what the requirement of the gnosis
is and
actually has it been served yet
can you answer that emma
yes i just get the enforcement notice up
in front of me
so the requirements of the enforcement
notice
was to remove the unauthorized dorm
window on the north
eastern side of the property so um
so currently it hasn't referred to the
materials of the other two dormers but
that that still could be subject to a
further enforce
enforcement notice but currently we've
asked for
for that to be for the dormer itself to
be removed
um we gave three months for that to
happen
they have appealed the enforcement
notice but only on the grounds of
extending the time period for those
works to take place and the inspector
agreed that that could be amended to six
months they've been given six months in
which to
to carry out those works and remove that
dormer
um the only thing i'm not sure about is
the actual um
time scale of when it was uh dated
september
2019 i'm just not sure with the appeal
decision actually how that's affected
the the final date but i for one
understand the enforcement notice is
served and they've been given six months
for removal
uh thank you emma uh councillor hart i'm
sorry chick can i just come back on that
point chair please
carry on yeah thank you um
so effectively um the the owners of the
property
have accepted that the contents of the
enforcement notice are fine
and that it should be removed and uh
and and all over and all over peeled on
is the time period that it should be
removed uh and under that
under that situation chair um i support
the officer's recommendation thank you
thank you councillor and um councillor
hart
hey chad uh yeah i think my question has
just been answered really
um so they would be forced to take off
the
the bigger dormer and put it back to how
it was on planning
is that is that correct
yes that's correct so they have planning
permission for the smaller dormer that
you saw in the
in the presentation so the enforcement
notice is required for the
for the um unlawful dormer to be removed
and then they can replace that with the
doorman that has had planning permission
thank you so ken so if it gets refused
will it
automatically mean that it goes back and
everything
goes back to how it was so it all has to
be a tall hung and everything else
um yeah what's the removal of the dormer
we would then expect the new dormer that
was put back
should be in accordance with the
approval the approval was for the
smaller dormer and that it was tauhan
as well um i believe because we've not
actually included the materials of the
other two dormers
in the notice i believe we would have to
then serve another enforcement notice
just to ask
them to change the materials of the
other two dormers to their tile hanging
thank you um i have counseled ghana
thank you yeah i just wanted to ask a
question um
during the during the presentation you
showed a number of other houses in the
street
with similar type dormers um
i'm just a little bit confused i know
maybe having a similar type dorm in a in
another house
up the road doesn't present the
president that this house
should have permission to have that
warmer but are are the other dormers in
the road
um similar or of the same type so
because it just so it seems a little bit
unfair to me
that they're they're looking up the road
that their neighbors
hang out with dormers that are similar
to the ones
they've built but yet they're being
asked
to take theirs down when the ones up the
road were given permission to
be give to be built
emma can you yeah um yeah i mean that
it's a very long road we've had a lot of
applications in for different roof
extensions along this road so there is a
huge variety
in the the different um types of
um dormer that have been erected on the
roofs we
we're not we can't find any exact
comparison between this proposal
um and any anything that exists in the
road yeah there are
like i say different size dormers but in
most cases they are tile hung so that
reduces the impact
um or if they have been um clad
it's because the whole building has been
um
redesigned so that it all ties in so in
terms of an oval design it
it it sits quite well because it's in in
keeping with the rest of the building
um i mean i can't say to you that any
the
how this compares in terms of size to
other properties in the road because
you know there are some slightly larger
dormers in the road some smaller dormers
but
i don't have any evidence to show what
exact size they were
of other dormers in the road but in
terms of this application
it's the cumulative impact of having
such a large dormer with a material
that's out keeping with the rest of the
property
and how that the cumulative impact of
that how that sits in terms of the
overall
appearance of it and um and views of it
within the street
thank you emma um council scott
thank you chair um yeah i i think it may
have been covered but i mean
i think as the officer highlighted one
of the
main issues was obviously the size but
also
the keeping in characters so i mean some
understanding
the uh applicant said that they could
basically re-tile they they could redo
that to keep into the character would
that effectively
put some movement on that
ever from there from one side from the
letter that was read out um
they said that they originally um said
they were happy to
to change the cladding to toll hanging
which as i said we would have accepted
but in addition we would have wanted the
dorm to be reduced in size
they're now saying they're not willing
to offer tile hanging as a solution they
would just be
looking at and painting the top that
painted the cladding to tie in with the
roof colour
which i personally see as a good
solution because
the painting of cladding it's you know
how that's going to look in terms of
you know 10 years time how that's going
to appear and also getting a color that
actually ties in with the roof
so i don't think we'd be um keen to
support that proposal
of the coloring of the cladding although
i appreciate that that would
be an improvement compared to the blue
grey cladding that we have because it
would be a bit more in keeping with the
roof color
but i don't think that alone is enough
for us to um overcome our concerns at
the moment
thank you um i cannot see any other
members wishing to speak
so i'm going to put this motion to
yourselves
which is uh the office recommendation is
to refuse once again i'm going to call
your names out and if you could
um for against or abstain i would be
grateful
so uh cancer coleman cook
against councillor auburn
for the office's recommendation yes
thank you for that council robin i
didn't make myself quite clear there
i think the members would have heard you
there uh councillor bakeford
against
councillor ruth duckworth full
nelson mike garner
against council david hart
for councillor pat moore
have we lost pat um we're back
are you back yes
uh against thank you thank you
uh councillor zesky for
councillor harry scoby for
councillor matthew scott abstain
counselling right four
and myself i'm four
emily i think that i believe would have
been
carried
thank you members that motion has been
carried
thank you
right sir that the applications that
have not been reserved
uh and determined by or in accordance
with the officer's recommendation
could i have a second please
um i need to call you i'll second that
um speak on them
it's it's yes is there is there any
members
wishing to speak on the applications at
all
i do chair if you could read re read
them out please
right i can read the right that's fine
um thank you emily
for a 65 downs road ram skate
yes i'd like to speak on that please
cheer
for a thank you for that emily
i've gone through your notes not the
agenda proper agenda
uh so we if we could move on to um
downs road who is
do we have anybody else to speak in i
don't think we do
mr livingston thank you chair
i'll just share my screen uh
with members
oh
um can you see the presentation members
that's a nice picture of mountains there
at the moment
oh okay apologies it's it's defaulted to
my other screen
bear with me sorry about this
that's just around the corner from downs
road i thought it was
right hopefully you might be able to uh
let me just present the screen there we
go
okay there we go
hopefully excellent thank you very much
okay so
the application site is outlined in red
so
this is uh you can see here downs road
and
children lane so we're in the chilton
park on the western end of
ramsgate
um so this is a detailed block plan
of the which shows actually the proposal
on it so the proposal is for
um a series of roof extensions on the
property
which includes front and rear door
windows
as well as a side and rear extension
that is proposed that you can see on
this block plan
so the thing question is uh next to this
red arrow
on this slide here and it is
uh bungalow that you can just see the
pitch of in the center of
the image
so this is what the property looks like
at the moment
so on the left hand side you have a pair
of bungalows
um as well as a bungalow on the right
hand side
so you can see the pair of bungalows
that are next to the properties that's
number 67
next door and then
you can see on the left hand side of the
image you can see the other
pair of bungalows that's the other side
of number 65 and then you can see
downs road um it to the right hand side
of the image
so you can see there is predominantly
the the road turns into
two-story properties but the immediate
vicinity of the site
is one of bungalows
so yeah here's an image just showing the
opposite side of the road
showing the the range of designs of
properties that are present on
downs road
so hit this is again knowing the block
plan i'm just going to show some images
of the the rear of the property
so it is looking down at
the bit at the back of of um downs road
so on the right hand side of this
image uh you have um what is uh number
67
um and then you've got so this is
another image just showing the existing
relationship
between the two properties
and then this is just the rear extension
so if i go back so this is the existing
rear extension that's going to be built
out onto the back of
so to the left you have number 63 to the
right of number 67
and then this is a view from the front
looking down between number 63
with number 65 on the left hand side
so you can see at the moment that
there's quite a separation distance
between
number 65 and number 63 in terms of
um habitable rooms in number 63
with the garage that's currently present
which is on the boundary between those
two properties
and then just looking down to see that
relationship
so the the side extension which is going
to be coming
out from the yellow bricked extension on
the left-hand side
would fill in the gap where where the
bins are you can see at the moment
so adjacent to that garage um
and then wrapping around that existing
rear extension
so in terms of the changes to the front
of the property
uh the proposal would increase the ridge
height of the property to be able to get
the
um roof accommodation in and that's what
what triggers the need for planning
permission for the for the roof
extension
with uh two dorm windows that are
proposed
within that front uh front elevation
um then moving back right you can
actually also sorry you can also see the
side extension
on the right hand side of the image here
adjacent to the the garage which has
been shown in outline form
uh that side extension is set back and
we'll look at the block plan at the end
as well so you can see that relationship
with the front
elevation with the front of the property
also being rendered
as well and you can see there's a change
in the design of the
of the sort of ground floor facade of
the building as well
and then here is the existing rear
extension and rear elevation which we've
looked at the photos of
and that would change with a rear door
window
going into the roof slope and then with
the extension which as mentioned builds
out to the side but also comes further
back
as well at the rear
so this is the side um elevation of
building so this is what face is number
63 where the the garage was that we saw
in the
in the photo
so you can see this extends out the back
again
um and also then you've got the actual
side
extend part as well so you see from this
image that the side extension part of
the of the proposal is set quite far
back into the site so way back from the
front elevation of of the property
and then this is the other side so this
is next to number 67
um and you can see again so on this side
it's extending the the rear extension
out and to the back
and then this is the ground floor plan
so again showing the
extent of of the extension that's
wrapping around
that existing single story extension on
the right-hand image
then you've got the existing roof plan
obviously which doesn't have any
accommodation in it
within the proposal to put a
dom windows front and back to serve a
new bedroom
at first floor and then this is a
section of the existing roof
and then a new section just showing
um what is proposed so let's go back to
the block plan to summarize the issues
the main issues for members to consider
are the impacts on the living conditions
of
neighboring properties as well as the
impact on the character appearance of
the area
um so in in officer's view the impact on
the character appearance of the area
there are no concerns with the rear
extension due to its location and the
fact that the side extension is set
quite far back into the site away from
the road in terms of the the dorm
windows
and the increase in ridge height there
is obviously as
as the images show a variety of designs
and properties
in the area um and whilst this is a
bungalow that's set between
two sets of bungalows i'm sorry one i
misspoke earlier one bungalow number 63
and and two two bungalows and i'm 67 and
69.
um that doesn't form the character of
the area
with the rest of downs road being quite
varied and obviously predominantly
two-story
very in very close proximity to this
site so we don't consider that the
uh the dorm windows that are proposed
are overly obtrusive or out of character
with the area
in terms of impact on neighbouring
properties you can see the relationship
that's proposed
shown in this block plan and obviously
we've seen the images showing
the relationship with those properties
um next door
so it's not protruding past the rear
extent of number 67
obviously to the left of this block plan
adjacent to number 65 and then in terms
of the impact on number 63
um it's obviously adjacent to a garage
but it's not
in close proximity to any habitable room
windows which would cause concern
potentially in terms of issues to do
with
sense of enclosure and that sort of
thing so overall it is considered that
it
is uh the the application is in
accordance with um
i can say this for the first time new
local plan policy uh qd02
um which is the character appearance
policy um and therefore
the recommendation is for approval thank
you chair
uh thank you very much ian um apologies
councillor alban i turned over a page
rather quick there so it's always good
to hear your voice
um coming in so my apologies
uh i moved the office recommendation
which had to be adopted um
which is to approve could i have a
second please i'll say
thank you uh thank you council com and
cook
um do you wish debate to debate this
members
if i could come in here exactly
yeah chair i i called this application
in
uh because when i first saw it and saw
the amount of
uh work that needed to be done to
completely change this
uh relatively small bungalowing in
conjunction with the others surrounding
it
it seemed quite a heavy amount of uh it
seemed over development of the site
um you know can i just ask
uh mr livingston if he could advise me
how high the roof has
increased
yeah thank you chair
um it's it's gone up by 700 mil
um so 0.7 of a meter um obviously that
does mean
that there's been an increase in the
roof pitch
um obviously to to accommodate that but
it is still a
it is you know it's still still a
pitched roof that's being being proposed
within the design
thank you thank you can i come back to
you
thank you um yeah i've i've got no
problem at all with the rear with the
rear extension as
uh mr livingston said it's it's set
quite back
on on the side and at the and at the
rear it goes in line with the adjacent
bungalows um i i am having slightly
different difficulty with
the uh the changing in the roof
um however i just like to
think on on that chair and see if any
other members want to say anything on
this
thank you thank you council auburn
i can't see any other members wish to
speak
no nobody's uh come up on my screen here
and peggy pond there has councillor
roseski
thank you chad yeah looking at uh the
drawings there and everything it all
looks quite uh
uh suitable for the area i will be
supporting this thank you
thank you councillor zesky um any other
speakers before this goes to vote
did you want to uh come back at all
councillor auburn
okay thank you thank you chair yeah um i
think on
on balance um
i will go along with the officer's
recommendation thank you thank you chair
thank you very much um the
recommendation is for approval so once
again
members um i will call out your names
and if you can
for if you're for it obviously
against if you're against and uh or
abstain
so woman cook
look for councillor
auburn four councillor bayford
four ounces of duckworth
four council ghana
full of heart
four counts one more
four councillor zesky
four councillor harry scoby
councillor scott four
and myself i'm four as well
so that looks so that has been motion
has been
carried
i always get clarification thank you
emily
um there are other other items on the
agenda
um i do
those agenda apologize out i know we've
done it once assembly but just to
make sure we've got it correct if there
any member wishes to speak on any of the
other items
um further public speaking um
that was all the public speaking items
covered so
move on to the next one item okay
so agenda item five it's the application
for a proposed
certificate of lawful development number
24
old crosston road margate i'd ask the
officer to read
says i believe it's in
i yes i'll just
um present my screen
um so just to confirm um for the record
emma fibbins has left the meeting
at this point um so
the this is an application for a
certificate of lawful development
um the reason this is being referred to
uh planning committee
is because uh the applicant in this
instance and in the subsequent agenda
item
um our employees of the council related
to employment of the council and under
the constitution
any application under planning
legislation submitted by
uh direct relations or or officers of
the council need to be referred
to members um so this
normal planning because as the report
outline
considerations in this instance are not
on a material planning consideration
based look at impact on character
appearance the area or
impact on neighbours um it's it's going
through the criteria
that's provided in the general committee
development order to see whether or not
that actually accords with the specific
case within that or
which outline what can be done without
needing
planning permission so i'll show you a
couple of the plans
and just touch on uh the relevant
permitted development rights
uh on this particular uh certificate
that's been submitted to us so
number 24 is in the center of the image
so what's being proposed
in this instance is a change
from a its roof to
a blend with a rear
window that's being proposed so um
this assessment for permitted
development rights uh
occurs under on this schedule two part
one
class b which looks at durations
specifically um in fact we've obviously
just had a couple of applications
related to roof alterations um so the
difference between those applications
and this application
um you can extend uh your
roof in terms of the accommodation that
you can get up there as long as you fit
specific criteria
one of the key criteria is that the
ridge height of the existing property
cannot increase
at all but also there is a specific new
content
that cannot be exceeded when extended
proof
so in this instance what else has done
is look at
plans that have been submitted and and
the roof extension
being proposed in this instance not over
40
cubic meters which is the upper limit
and therefore uh in accordance with the
other cons as well
mentioned as being firms of the dorm
window
and the hip to gable part of the roof
extension
accord is the criter the relevant
courier also
one of the other conditions of that
specification is that materials have to
match
the existing property so in this
instance the dorm window at the rear is
to be
tile hung in terms of the side
elevation of the of the proposed
uh extension and what's being put here
is
a side window so under the general
development order sites are permitted
but only when they are obscure glazed
and also non-opening uh above
1.7 meters from the finished floor level
of the property so in this instance the
window has been shown to be obscure
glazed with
only an opening above 1.7 above that
finished floor level
of the upper floors so in offices view
it complies
with the requirements of the general
committed development order
and therefore it's recommended to
members that the certificate is granted
thank you chair uh thank you ian i move
the officer's recommendation is adopted
um could i have second to please
oh second second i think accounts common
cook
do you wish to debate this
i can't see anybody coming up on my
screen here so
uh right so once again uh
if you know how this works now four
against rob stain please i'm calling
your name out
um counselor coleman cook
for council bayford
torture counselor pat moore
four yeah george frazewski
four councillor harry scobee
four councilman matthew scott
did i leave you out
against me today sharon yeah i know i
know i would have a go at you steve yeah
counselor four
i know why but i don't you know my fault
my fault
that has been carried thank you very
much
uh moving on now to agenda item
six an application for proposed
certificate of lawful development
three upton grange
is that yourself again
it is chair uh i will thank you my
screen again
um so this um
remembers again a nice tour of the
permitted development rights today
uh so this is another certificate of
allotment again
not considering the merits of the case
but whether or not the criteria has been
met
um so this is a the property
in question what's being put forward
here
is a series of extensions um so not roof
extensions so
not under class b of uh schedule two
part
one of the general price development
order but under class
a so this is um
a series of extended the side
and rear that are proposed um
so this is the property in question you
can see this is an existing plan
um what's being proposed and i was
skipped the the side
and elevations that will show it's a bit
better um so what's being proposed in
this instance
is a single story side extension within
an extension
here as well and it does include in this
instance
a an extension to a two-story
bit of the property at the back so it
actually includes a two-story
extension on it so under the permitted
development order
um two-story extensions are allowed
when um there is a specific distance
uh over and above which you can extend
uh two stories
from the rear boundary of the site or to
any boundary of the site
so the general public development order
was changed in 2015
to allow for you know additional
extensions when
they're not in close proximity with no
properties
um since again the assessment has been
made um
the materials have been confirmed to be
to match
uh the existing property um previously
um pd rights under this class were on
the basis of again on
cubic content but that's no longer the
case so it's all about the relationship
with the boundaries and how far you are
away
boundaries as well as whether or not in
the case of side extensions you're
actually extending
over and above half the width of the
property
so in this instance all the criteria
have been met
by the application and therefore it's
recommended to members that the
certificate is granted
thank you chair thank you and i move
that the officer's recommendation
is adopted could i have a second please
second nature thank you is there anyone
who wishes to speak
no okay so i'm going to put this to the
vote once again
uh councillor common cook for
councillor alban
didn't wish for that time council
bayford four
councillor duckworth full
council ghana four councillor heart
four answer pat moore for
councillor zesky four
councillor scoby four announcer scott
campbell all right four
and myself uh four
okay and let's look so it's being
carried
thank you very much that motion has been
carried
okay moving on to agenda item seven
application again for a non-material
amendment
to planning permission at number nine
edmondson avenue market
is this yourself uh ian you're doing
what
it is yes thank you i know you want to
get it um so
so this is uh uh slightly different from
the previous ones so this is
um again um it's coming before members
as a council employee
um this is um actually for a
non-material amendment to a previous
approval
um in this instance um in officer's view
it's
it's very straightforward in so much as
um
the application was for a series of
extensions at the rear of the property
um as well as some alterations i will
just skip through these photos which
show so
there are no changes proposed under the
non-material amendment procedure
uh to the front of the property um in
terms
of what's actually changing from the
permission
what's what's changing in this instance
is the rear extension is actually
getting smaller
so if i go to the image of the floor
plans
you can see what's what's happened in
this instance is it was approved with a
6.8 meter extension at the rear but it's
actually
only extending by 5.8 meters in this
instance
in terms of the other change that's
occurring is the roof flight that was
previously serving
the staircase um is actually effectively
um it's it's it's changing in terms of
where it is
because um it's actually moving up the
roof slope slightly
so um this particular procedure is to
consider whether or not
the changes that are being proposed are
material or not and whether or not they
do have an impact on the permissioners
granted
as there is a reduction in size in this
instance it's not considered that
there is any any material change to the
planning permission as granted
uh and therefore it's recommended uh to
approve this
this non-material amendment thank you
chair uh
thank you ian i move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted could i have a
second
please secondly
council russeski i believe that was uh
okay members do you wish to debate this
at all
okay i'm going to put this to the vote
with yourselves i think you know how
this works now so if i call your
name out uh councillor coleman cook
four counts robin
four councilman batehood four
councillor duckworth four
council ghana four councillor heart
oh counselor pat moore
what monster zesky or
counselor scoby
four councillor scott four
council right and myself of four
thank you members uh officers uh that
includes this afternoon's planning
meeting
thank you very much um i believe we are
due to meet in
two weeks time as a normal meeting
um so thank you for your attendance this
afternoon
i will get more